what do they say beauty is pain or pain
is beauty
wow
so what was your first big tattoo
i think
it was probably a stomach test oh wow
yeah so you're but that guy he didn't
cry
so i mean you know to me this is more
special
because we're sort of connected in more
of an emotional way
because you cried before but i didn't
cry before i just made noises
[Music]
thick boy
thick light
better do it big you don't live twice
you don't get a chance to do it again
let me show you what the thick light
feels like
thick light
thick nation
big nation
thick light
big nation you know we do it right never
do it light it's the thick light
i'm gonna tattoo man and i'm getting in
a spot where
it's gonna
it's gonna [ __ ] me up you know i don't
do well with tattoos in general but i
always get them
my god about how long
three four hours for real
i can't sit there for this oh
you sit still
25 minutes
[Music]
uh chappelle's getting a [ __ ] tattoo
of one of his favorite songs by one of
his favorite bands
nervous breakdown
this is going to hurt me more than it's
going to end yeah
[Music]
yeah
like bad or
not bad
i'm sure the cream's up is it what does
it feel like i mean i feel it you know
yeah it's a [ __ ] tattoo
or way less than you thought mentally
uh i thought it'd be worse than the
oh
that's where he goes he spoke too soon
independent where he goes i thought it'd
be worse
right here is rough like by the belly
button area like right here just down
here
yeah that's where he's going right now
i see you
okay
the rocky rocky soundtrack
[Music]
oh my god
all right man we're all done let me know
if you uh
let me know if you want to keep it
yo what's up guys today we're at
signature track studio and we're working
on the thick boy album
[Music]
so this is signature track studio we got
chin in here yo what up we got mark
harley up in here what up we got the
genius behind it all ready
and um yeah today we're gonna be getting
some vocals and working on the album so
shout out to all the thick boys and
thick girls out there let's go haters
will say i ain't natural duck and get
[ __ ] with a spatula then watch me
catapult off on a handle hit a triple
backflip and land on your sandy vagina
like damn
but i was only just kidding i'm really
just pissed that you're winning
sitting in mommy's converting garage
while i'm benching on cheetos to
spinning
okay that's what you're saying what you
should do is say the damn with it okay
because then it'll make you land yeah
i was totally just kidding that's how
you're gonna do it haters will say i
ain't natural y'all can get [ __ ] with
a spatula then watch with catapult off
of the handle hit a triple backflip and
land on your sandy vagina like damn
bro i was only just kidding i'm pretty
just pissed that you're winning
sitting in mommy's converted garage
while i'm binging on cheetos just
venting
haters will say they're not triggered
but your man who just keeps getting
bigger but they'll be talking
hypertrophy or my ig or the size of my
dick or whatever you need to convince
yourself that you're not an intel who
should kill yourself that your actions
are lying out a yell for help till the
therapist gets here just hold the l
[Music]
with the big boy brother
this new podcast but i'm gonna still
watch that [ __ ]
something the hater was saying
haters will say haters will say haters
will say anything every day every day
just to make sure you'll chase your
dreams you're gonna go i'm gonna stay so
say anything you want to be haters
[Music]
enough all we got to do is
just like airplane yeah you know what
i'm saying a lot of [ __ ] think
just just because i'm a meathead don't
rape
[Music]
i can't imagine quitting cause this is
thick boy brand new with new drip boy
walked right in got a lit boy came right
back with the hiss boy 90 everything
fickle ain't really messed with the kid
back then not everything that i do big
boy that's how you know you're rocking
with the big boy
this album is for all the thick boys big
girls out there just the lifestyle of
trying to do it big and make everything
thick
um actually tomorrow will be one year
since i did the king and the sting album
for brennan and theo so now this year
it's all about the thick boys and thick
girls
yeah man we just started making some
bangers and now we've got some cool
people on the album super excited to put
it out
[Music]
dominic cruz got dropped it looks like
he's about to lose but he's coming back
now so i don't know what's going to
happen
mma the beauty be careful dude because
i've been training real hard i was about
to i had a jean jack and i took it off
you look at james cause you can't be one
i'm very lucky i would have gone
shirtless dude
and i had to change because i was
getting on my car and i stayed in the
entire side
oh the dirt yeah
good thing about this in the car
yeah good thing good thing man it looks
real yeah come on
well we're here again at the um
fight companion i fight around the
companion i like to call it and um
it's uh it's it's gonna be lit i think
you know what i mean i think it's gonna
be lit dude and i'm really excited about
this one because my beard length is the
right [ __ ] length
i don't really you know i tri this is
what i do i let it grow and then i cut
it down
and i cut it down and then whatever day
it is that i got to be on camera that's
what length you get and it just so
happened that right now tonight
it's at the best length for [ __ ]
cameras so let's go
i love it my f8 stuck at the port too
that's nice oh really oh never got it
it's been stuck at the porch you got
yours is an nft though right it doesn't
actually exist
it's not here i haven't seen it
this guy's not easy to put away man
that's why she stand up john's
impressive
uppercut shot oh hello
here we are calabasas what are we doing
in the fight companion what did we do
we lived it to the fullest it was
unexpected i wanted to see poirier win
the title tonight i thought it was
inevitable i thought he was definitely
the much better fighter but oliveira
really pushed it
got shocked by pena
uh sugar shane did what he expected cody
lost which is really sad but all in all
was an amazing night and i just tried to
push abundance on the guys let's just
live a life of abundance
rob fit right in
and i basically now i'm going to live my
life the way rob lives his life i'm
going to break down everything and i'm
going to use that what was the word he
used uh i don't even know the word god
damn it i [ __ ] it up already dude it
was really fun i had a good time and uh
ate a piece of pizza drank two coffees
dude oh my god and my beard length was
the right length
and that just happened to be how it was
every first of all they might be too big
you're welcome i think that i uh i
brought the heat tonight and you know
you think it was rob it's probably rob
it's probably wrong rob rob
no he didn't win dude nobody's winning
this bob came in he dropped some knives
i think that was our best podcast yet i
mean the best fight companion that was
good
for me at least the most fun the the the
just the energy the flow was the best
because rob knows you're welcome
you think it was you you're welcome no
no you can't take full credit for that
boy
boy provides a mom
you think it's you anything it's rob i
mean rob's great
right i like how your voice is
you're welcome
all right okay well all right well you
guys finished up your post interview
what's your name is podcast podcast
called you finished your post interview
guys
we're trying to finish this dude
it's late
he's a good companion man
great campaign one of the best yeah and
brian is gonna be in united now now i'm
glad you asked december 22nd wednesday
one night one show only eight p.m at the
hollywood improv it's you me and friends
now we have some funny friends and
speaking of friends you'll be
you'll be there at the child six houses
i'm not going to be the people i'm not
i'm not
but you never know though you never know
i'm not there anything's possible nope
anything's possible talking to rob i
will figure out money and it's possible
hang out with robin how do i do it i
know it made me feel so poor i'm so
presence to him
dude he was off camera he's just oh
we're educating on why i need to do what
i do this podcast should be called
support it should be called support
so anyway you rob make you feel like
you're losing kansas city i'll see you
december 17th 18th two shows only friday
saturday and then oklahoma city
bricktown
i'm coming i'm so jealous and then uh he
go see him in oklahoma city new year's
and i will be in florida at fort
lauderdale dania florida december 31st
through january 1st the thick boys are
coming rob is going to do a ted talk
there he's going to do a tech talk on
money
how not to
really know how to ruin your life and
how to be optimized
all right that's it enjoy